so let's get to reading and all of this
from lieutenant chris oliveiras of the
texas department of public safety
uh chris uh the clock is ticking i'm
really intrigued by that tent uh city
going up of the whole 500 people from
what i've read there's been 1.8 million
or so expulsions uh since title 42 went
to
into operations it does it doesn't seem
like that's going to be enough space uh
to be able to handle the deluge that's
expected
right good afternoon charles so what you
see right there of course with building
illusionist report on about that soft
sided facility there um and also with
what it's doing uh also charles take
into account is that it's depleting
federal resources so now you have border
patrol agents so you have to staff that
facility all it's going to mean charles
that it's going to encourage these
immigrants to make a journey to continue
to come across in the united states
because they're going to be processed
and essentially released to the united
states so
even with title 42 and claims we've seen
all the video that's taken place right
there the vast groups that are coming
across especially there in eagle pass
texas and that's only less than one mile
of an area where we're seeing these
groups come across every single day so
right now what we are focusing on as a
state is working with our international
partners in mexico so that they can take
a more aggressive stance on their side
by surging resources to contain and
deteriorate those surges those groups
that are coming across the border on the
mexican side how confident are you that
that will happen
well charles you know ever since
governor i haven't launched or ever
since governor abbott initiated those
agreements with the governors of mexico
and we had we also started those
enhanced safety commercial vehicle
inspections we saw what took place at
the ports of entry and we saw that it
forced mexico to surge resources at the
border now again what you're seeing
right there obviously we know that it's
not working or they don't have the
resources there in place but right now
with our state leadership within our
agency or having consistent
conversations with mexican authorities
and i can tell you right now this coming
week we will have bi-national operations
throughout the southern border and del
rio loreto and other areas of interest
we can focus on these increased
crossings that are taking place so
earlier today homeland security
secretary alejandro mayokos was talking
about how the administration is going to
deal with all of this take a listen
chris
back in september of last year
we started to plan and prepare for the
eventual end of the cdc's use of title
42 and that is in fact what we have done
and i am going to go down to mcallen
texas tomorrow
it's my i think 9th or 10th visit to the
border and explain to local officials
exactly what our plans and preparations
involved
so chris first uh off you're going to be
seeing secretary marcus when he goes to
mcallen what exactly do you want to hear
from him
you know well charles you know we've
been hearing the
the conversations ever since last year
when this process took place about
having a plan in place well it's one
thing to have a plan on paper but you
have to effect that plan take a pro take
an aggressive stance take proactive
measures and focus on what the what the
issues are that's border security if
this was the case we wouldn't have saw
what we saw last year with the haitians
in the real we saw 17 000 plus search
the border all at once and because what
we've been able to do as a state by
providing insurgent resources along the
border with national guard we've been
able to deter any other caravans from
making their way to the border so a
question i would have and also i mean i
think we should be answered is what when
are you gonna actually put this plan in
place and take a stance a more
aggressive stance in securing the border
protecting the local smaller border
communities
providing more resources to border
patrol so they can focus on what they
are
uh primarily
good at and that's securing the border
going after criminals going after drug
smugglers but right now that's what
needs to be achieved right now charles i
believe from the secretary and i think
as as far as we continue moving forward
as a state we're going to continue
having these conversations with mexico
but again we're having to bear this
burden right now because again the
federal government's not taking any
responsibility of what's taking place do
you plan to see uh secretary america's
tomorrow
i won't be in the valley charles i'm
actually in west texas right now i'm
actually here going to cover some other
elements that are taking place here um a
different element that we're seeing here
in the west texas area as far as border
security so i will not be there but i'm
curious to see what's going to take
place and what's going to come out of
those conversations
yeah you and a whole lot of people
including a lot of democrats uh who are
actually elected officials down there
everyone's concerned chris thank you
very much appreciate it
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now